thank you for being here today it's
awesome to have such a big crowd already
I'm not sure how many you are there
online but welcome to
today we're going to speak a bit about
Python and Julia I prepared a couple of
notebooks which you can use to
interactively join me today
and yeah please if you can turn on the
screen
it's a bit small but yeah I also posted
it in the Discord channel of this very
room it's the a05 oh six
and this also the name of the Discord
Channel and yeah it's under Tulane to
lane.io
here because in GitHub it's not possible
and then a workshop accelerate python
with Julia and actually if you go just
to the
GitHub organization you already see it
pinned at the top so here the the fourth
one this is
our material for today
we're getting more and more so for those
who join later you can always Point them
to the Discord channel so this is where
it's now there also for those who join
in later
um so that they can hook in into our
session
so if you are at this Repository
um
yeah I prepared kind of three points
Let's see we we cut a little bit here
and there so I think we make everything
today but I also want to have time for
questions so we'll be a bit flexible
and yeah all this material is
online available for you thanks to
mybinder.org I guess most of you know
this organization and the lovely Jupiter
notebooks it supports for us and I'm
also using this today we have two
introduction sessions for Julia
and then a final little example where I
took one example from the web quite
recent and put this yeah into Julia as
well so that we can compare some
performances from python to site and C
plus plus and Julia so we won't go into
all the details here the main part is
that you understand it's actually easy
to use Julia in order to speed up your
python code where you need it
okay so in case this happens and
internet breaks down on this very repo
there's also a way to spawn the things
locally on your laptop the links will be
a bit broken then but you will manage
still yeah this spawns everything on
your own laptop you need Docker and
Jupiter able to Docker for this but it's
really lovely
um other than that it's the same
environment okay so we got a bit more
and because we only have one and a half
hours it's not too much to get into a
new language
um I'm going to start into the first
notebook so I'm just clicking this very
link here on the content page and yeah
and this will open
a new
link yeah so this should look similar
for you and I tested this before if
binder was not kicking out my Docker
cache then this should start up within a
couple of seconds
and yeah
we are lucky the image is still there
and soon it's there and the same should
be kind of similar for you
of course it depends a bit on your
connectivity also binder is not
Unlimited
I really hope this works
and in case it doesn't there's always
this local installation
and yeah
but it looks so far
kind of okay
[Music]
um
so I hope this starts within a minute at
least usually it works a bit faster but
I think thousands are joining right now
so I opened the pre-open binder
wow we're getting more and more
welcome everyone
so with short words about me
I'm Stefan let me make this a little bit
larger even
and taking of the view okay
so I'm Stefan Zam
I'm one of the Julia enthusiasts in
Germany and yeah about one and a half
years ago I started my own company
to offer two-year consultancy in Germany
it's called jolene.com
and they are progressing Market is still
very small but yeah as you see there's a
huge potential also in this technology
um even a bit longer I organized the
Julia User Group Munich
started two two and a half years ago and
we're kind of a monthly mostly online
mostly online
set up because of Corona the last years
were a little bit online driven so I'm
very thankful to have this session in
person again
and yeah other than that I came from
Academia from stochastics applied
mathematician I am and I also did
cognitive science that was kind of my
study Choice back then which I really
love and I can totally recommend versus
cognitive science study and yeah if you
want to chat I also like to chat about
philosophy of mind and this stuff so
yeah really like these topics but also
stochastics and yeah and from my daily
life I'm in the Big Data field and
getting things into production
Okay so
let's see so I hope
huh
okay so this should have been up within
a second
so
can you give me a hands up who was able
to get a binder running
okay these are a couple only who was
trying to get a binder running but it
wasn't succeeding who failed so far
okay this is less that's good so I'm
sorry for those who have the same fate
that I have
so
um apparently
my binder
okay so fall back
um so at least those who have this they
can join and I will kick in the
alternative and spawn it locally
so I pre-compiled it the first time
would be a bit longer for you because I
already did it I'm I'm already there
and you should directly go to the
notebooks itself
so but I am now kind of in my local
version of the binder but actually now
the other binder also came up so yeah
just tried a couple of times
okay after this little introductory how
to get access to the platform
we are ready to start and I would
directly start because to lose too much
time but it's really because we are here
in person it would be great if you have
kind of some questions here please raise
them I try to do the best to be on track
with the time but I really like to take
a couple of questions so I need to calm
down a couple of others if we get too
much questions but yeah this is really
one of the advantages to be interactive
okay first test there white on the back
I'm not sure how I can hear you but give
it a try
yeah so um the link is on Discord if you
go to the Discord Channel
it's a good one
um
for the online audience there were two
questions about it related so it's the
question how to reach the Discord
Channel and
and I don't know
yeah you can
yeah that's the probably the easier one
then if you go to github.com to lean and
dash IO this is uh the company GitHub
and they are pinned you find the
workshop accelerate python with Julia
you're right this is actually a good
shortcut so to lean Dash IO
because of URL constraints okay and then
you can join us with the first part by
clicking on the link in the outline
so let's go ahead so we have these three
parts I already mentioned two times
going into Julia and one in the last
part getting
um yeah a kind of toy example but still
an example where you really get a
feeling of comparing different languages
so let me get a bit more
space
um Okay so
one for the question please
yeah yeah thank you
so I hope
um it's better
thank you Christian Morris um to zoom in
you got it so if you want to start
learning Julia
I also have a couple of links at the end
but this one is kind of the most
important there's a learning section at
the official Julio
webpage and there you can find a lot of
more
a lot more information so today we are
mainly using one package it's called
Julia call and this is my recommendation
for you it has kind of the best defaults
to exchange between Python and Julia
and yeah we completely focus on this
package today
and we can so I set up this environment
everything's installed and if you
installed it you can from Julia call
import Main and it's usually the
documentation recommenders and I like
this rename to JL stands for Julia and
it has also a lovely
ipyton extension so that we can use
Magics we can use cell magic and line
Magics to access Julia a bit more
conveniently
okay so this has a little bit more
output and with this tiny screen it's
full in a second but it's really kind of
fast just setting up a couple of things
and then we are ready to go and we have
this lovely Julia
command it's now the line magic and if
you execute the first two cells you you
already have kind of a working Julia
environment linked to the python
environment what we did here is just we
activated the project
um this where we notebook is in
to use a couple of packages which are
defined in there and we also load python
call which is the opposite so that's
Julia call for the pythonside and python
call now for the Julia site and we use
this to to get everything working
so yeah
um
this little helper here said Vara is a
kind tiny trick to easier get things
from python to Julia and for example now
I have this little
number of iterations
and I use this now from the JL which we
imported and with DOT I can now access
anything in the Julia Main namespace and
as we just defined a function here
um I can now access it so this is a tiny
function definition in Julia two
arguments and we're Now setting them the
key and the value and this works
okay so
one part of this Workshop is to get you
kind of deep into how you can interact
with these two languages hence it will
be a bit dense here and there to get
kind of the basics of Julia but as you
all know python I think this is not kind
of a huge drawback but you will get the
language really quickly you will see
it's super similar and if you're now a
bit more of Matlab even then you feel
more familiar
um the syntax is actually more Matlab
like but yeah
from the style you're working very
similar to python okay so let's start
and um in this introduction notebook I
just look into two things this is the
numpy arrays and data frames and it's
super tiny but still kind of gives you a
good idea so we set up a little numpy
array which is actually up to a thousand
but yeah we just print the first 10. so
you can play a little bit with this
number n and compare performances but
yeah a thousand is kind of okay to get a
start so this is here just python yeah
here we are still in Python and now we
use the cell magic Julia and now we
switch to Julia and in Julia we have
kind of this lovely ad here which is
called the macro this re-wraps our code
and does some fancy things and this part
here it's very simple it just also
prints the name of the variables we put
in so you see here that we're printing
also the name itself and yeah and this
is impossible in Python but the nice
thing if you have macros available
so yeah the tiny thing and what we do
here we we set our numpy array yeah with
a via our set there Little Helper and
now we have it also in the Julio world
and you see that our
um Julia Carl and Payton call was
putting this into a special wrapper it's
called Pi array on the Julia side so
this is a good compromise you can get
kind of faster
code depending kind of if you have a
specific numpy array with only floats
yeah you can get a better representation
on Julia but this is a good General
representation and you also see it
captures also kind of some some type
information about what is in there
and it actually has kind of good
performance so this is kind of real now
a little other function we're just
doubling things and Julia you don't need
to put the multiplication sign between a
number and the variable
it's just a nice idea and this one is
the first thing I want to show you that
in Julia you can broadcast any function
you define so this is not a super tiny
function you know it doesn't really make
sense but you can imagine yeah you have
your own complex logic and you just want
to broadcast it over your array
and enjoy you just put a dot in front
and if you have multiple arrays yeah and
they are different dimensions then
broadcast logic comes into play if
you've played with numpy you know this
yeah then the other dimensions are
filled up
and yeah and this just works and this is
quite nice and we can also show Okay so
this broadcasting now switched the time
to the internal
um Julia array type it's um if it's only
one dimension it's called vector
so this is just a little intro to that
you see okay we there's some cares
taking about the type so that everything
is kind of nice and works and we also
get a nice output so this is standard
Julia output a Julia Vector is usually a
column vector so a bit different than
numpy but numpy actually also supports
column vectors so there's also kind of a
synergy
and because we just had a cell I'm using
this underscore to get access to the
last return variable to see what this
thing is actually on python side
and we see that this is a special class
so this is no longer a Julia Vector
itself but it's wrapped into a python
thing and here's called Vector value but
actually this gives access to the Julia
side so nothing is copied yeah this
whole
um Julia called python call is really to
have no copy at all and we just yeah
refer to the other side and we can also
make a copy and this one here is now the
next line yeah if we just wrap it
um many numpy functions work out of the
box with this Vector value as well yeah
so you don't need to care so often but
in case you want to cast explicitly to a
numpy array just put it into an Empire
and then you are there
okay so here we got kind of two Julia
and back for a little tiny example
multiplying it by two and again dividing
it by two one question here in the front
statements yeah
um so online I was a question an evil
statement in the third plot
ah yeah so
so this is a helper yeah I I promised
you you won't get all the details
um so the evil one is um just the normal
thing where you can execute code in a
language so in Python you have this too
you can get a string yeah and I'm not
sure where this evil exists or not
concretely
um but you can execute an arbitrary
string and in Julia
um you not do you you're not you don't
necessarily need to use a string but
Julia itself has a meta representation
of itself it's um yeah meta language
like lisp and hence you you don't need
to always write this string and with a
macro in front this is this at sign yeah
so this always means okay here's some
meta logic going on rewriting the code
so this is yeah you can think of this
like a string pass to the evil but in
Julia we don't need to always use
strings because we have this meta level
and then this is really just
interpolation like in a string you also
have this or on bash yeah yeah the
dollar signs always interpolation and
yeah we
we put uh yeah k equals y here as code
and evaluated and because we get this as
dynamically variables we need to insert
them somehow in this string and then it
gets executed first so yeah we actually
have the variable n
thank you for the question and yeah okay
so I'm going on so where we've been
we've seen
um that we can go back and forth and
yeah and now first part yeah this is all
the boats beating up stuff so you'll see
a couple of mini benchmarks and they are
all somehow stupid yeah be with me it's
also for demonstration purposes but
you'll see there's some truth for it
yeah so take every Benchmark with a
grain of salt
there are depends on the system depends
on what you do how yeah how far you
scale
but but still it's good so we can time
things and we can see and if you have
kind of a specific case time a specific
case profile it and you see kind of what
is
yeah what is Law and what to speed up
so these are we're using the IPython
helper time it
this is one of the benefits of being in
the Jupiter notebook in pure python this
is not available but in Jupiter
thankfully we have it in IPython and we
see kind of the standard list
comprehension with a thousand we have a
couple of microseconds and we can put
the same range object to Julia and time
it here
and Bam we see the first speed up okay
so of course I made this so I expect a
couple of speed UPS and um
yeah and interestingly so if you put
down the number of iterations to a
hundred yeah then it's no longer faster
actually so this is a typical thing here
if you yeah have less iterations then it
may not make sense to switch the
language yeah so but if you have a
couple of iterations then it makes more
sense but actually already for a
thousand we get kind of a good speed up
here of course this is plain python
um so let's look into numpy we have our
numpy array and we can also multiply
this by two and get the the differences
and what we do here now is we always use
this um time it helper and the time it
is of course the python side yeah so if
we now have the second test here we go
to Julia and go back to python yeah so
this is of course a little overhead and
hence yeah actually it really is much
much slower here but if we now want to
test kind of the pure Julia we can also
do this on Julia itself so this would
not account for the switching yeah
depending on the context if you need to
account for the switching so yeah always
mind what you're going what you want to
test but just for comparison to see kind
of what Julia can offer you
um we're using Benchmark tools the
little Julia package which has the
b-time macro and also Benchmark mushroom
which we're going to look into later
and I'm going to I have two timings here
I want the the double
application to the numpy array and one
time where we first converted to a Julia
Vector so this is now pure Julia and see
the performance on the pure Julia array
so as you see it's not so far away yeah
so
um we
we are kind of in the range of numpy
depending on whether we use the numpy
area itself a bit slower
if we put truly a bit faster but this is
really kind of your noise anyway so
these tiny numbers they are kind of
similar so if you execute this a second
time you will see different values
okay so that was the first benchmark
and I have another little benchmark
just to convince you that there is some
power behind we'll see a bit more of
that and yeah so what we're going to do
here is just matrix multiplication and
python we have this add sign which
someone came along to have matrix
multiplication operator wise and and
Julia we just use multiplication
because we have this dot for
broadcasting so for element wise
multiplication you can use Dodge
multiply
and yeah and if we go the first time so
again here we have the the python
version we are slower passing things to
Julia doing the matrix multiplication
there is slower and if we do the same
thing in Julia
now we get the speed up yeah and this
now is already a bit more drastically so
small mattresses yeah
so we have one what's this actually
doing is one vector standing on one
vector laying yeah of a thousand and we
do the matrix multiplication here to get
this down to a single value
and yeah so this is already much faster
than numpy
yeah so take your preferred case and now
you can experiment a little bit Yeah if
you have a numpy thing which you often
use yeah give it a try look whether you
can just use this and already speed up
stuff a little bit so you see it's
really tiny and yeah still are we going
to look this in a second yeah
so we for now have used the Jupiter
helpers with the Magics the cell Magics
but it's kind of the same if you doing
it programmatically so you can really
think of these benchmarks as something
you can use right away in your python
code
so it's just a little bit more handy now
to use the stupidermatics
okay so this was intended to be
interactive so I put a little your
spaces here and there and
as always we need to be cautious about
the time
and yeah the first 30 minutes are
already going to an end
so I think I'll skip this
I was expecting this to happen I'm sorry
but yeah you you understand my situation
we want to cover a couple of content but
be invited yeah go back to this Jupiter
notebook and try a couple of different
iteration numbers try your favorite
numpy
and numpy Method and map it to Julia and
see a couple of speedups
okay so
um yeah so we still need to I want to
show you kind of what you would do if
you don't have a Jupiter so Jupiter we
have this nice extra that we can also
write files
and in this sense you can think of this
now just as a plain text file we have
some Julia code is in and this would be
I think the preferred way yeah to to
write Julia extension because then you
have the best IDE Support also so you
just write it in a Julia file you just
put it next to your python yeah python
code right there and then from the
python side you can call the special
function string evil we're seeing the
evil on the top and now we have the
evaluate also here with a string form
and when Julia we have this extra
command called include
just use as a function and we pass the
file name
and yeah and with this everything in the
file is loaded into the current Julia
session
and yeah so the magic parent really is
just in time compilation so this is
really optimal yeah there's no
difference in writing it before and
loading it with with Julia somehow or
yeah calling the include this is really
the same you don't need to be afraid
that you get kind of some performance
penalties
you can also use the as Evo directly
yeah if you prefer this then you can use
kind of standard python but mind that
there's a begin and end needed if you
have multiple commands so tiny little
thing
and it's always good to kind of not to
not have too many obstacles so and then
we can also call this little my function
and yeah and what we have now is just we
have the arguments and the keyword
arguments and we output them and yeah
you see kind of some extra thing we want
to go on the detail here but you see
kind of you how you can use it from
python itself
at least one question
operator
can we expect these speedups for all
operators or is there a trade-off
somewhere okay so the question from the
online audience is that
um whether or how the speedups behave
which we can expect if we have similar
speedups like we see like a factor of 10
and and how yeah how to get intuition
where we get in a speed everywhere not
and I think the best intuition is like
the more individual you get yeah so if
you have really individual tiny things
you want to compute then Julie gives you
a huge speed up yeah because all the
numpy ecosystem this works by yeah
making things vectorized yeah and have
kind of standard numeric types and and
crunching them on the seaside and Julia
gives you the power to just Define your
own types get everything in there and
have also the speed up on just a few
iterations yeah and and this I think is
where you can expect the huge speedups
but still
um Julia shows kind of a couple of extra
speed UPS if you plug in many tools yeah
so if you have kind of numpy and you do
a lot of things here and there you still
need to go to Python and back to to see
you have kind of some
friction here and there and the Julia
side kind of also has an advantage here
if you have complex systems which need
to interact you get rid of this friction
sometimes but always kind of give it a
try and Benchmark it that's the easiest
to see
slash watch out for something in terms
of exchanging
from memory
yeah okay so the question is whether
it's an extra Julia runtime and it is
but it's in this case using Julia call
it's really kind of tightly bound to
python so that we have the pointers
going back and forth and not copying the
data at least this is the default you
can also copy the data if you want but
the default is not copying
and there's no jvm so this is uh yeah
not Java Julia compiles down with llvm
like C plus plus or rust so it's a the C
family on the Julia side
okay so yeah last part for this year is
to give you just a tiny thing for data
frames so data frames are also supported
in Julia and I just think that most of
you use numpy for arrays and data
panders or polar for data frames and in
Julia we also have data frame library
and it's yeah also optimized for Speed
so one thing in Julia is that people
optimize for Speed so you can expect
high performance and yeah so this is
patent side always mine we don't have a
Julian front just getting some example
data frames this is taken from this link
where the data frames package in Julia
has a comparison how you can get from
pandas to data frames.jl and then Julia
it's quite similar we actually have a
bit easier we can use just keyword
arguments directly to set up the columns
and yeah and yeah the the group by and
mean looks massively different but has
couple of advantages doing it that way
and yeah
both both are kind of fine but yeah
there's this link here at the top this
gives you a little table of how to go
from panders to to Julia
okay so also a little Benchmark here
um this again uses our n
we just group stuff it's super stupid uh
what you be invited to to get some
fancier examples so just two groups and
we sum up uh a couple of integers and
doing this on python
and doing this on Julia we again see
kind of a factor of five here yeah so
it's again a super tiny example but the
key thing is it makes sense to give
Julia a try if you want to speed up
things
okay so again a little tiny your space
look into the link I put there and try
some other mappings from pandas to
dataframes.gl
okay this is the end of the first part
and I compiled here a couple of further
resources where I can look into if you
want to do more of this part and next
week go into another notebook format I
definitely wanted to show you this it's
called Pluto and the main difference to
Jupiter is that Pluto is reactive
but unfortunately Pluto is Julia only at
this time
so yeah still because this is also truly
a session uh we can give it a try so
click on next notebook
um
this will open binder so this is the
case if you are if you have the local
installation the links won't work
and this is because they point to Pi to
binder but there's an URL path in the
binder part at the very end
and this is the thing you just need to
place at the end of your local
and then also the local installation
works okay
the reboot to Docker if you if you use
the repo to Docker local installation
like I did
um
then you just need to copy the the last
part URL path
and place it into your uh what's here
one
127.0.0.1 so most of you will use binder
for those it's not interesting but if
you have the the local version
uh okay
and yeah okay
so I hope for most of you binder still
works
and I'm proceeding locally okay so the
Pluto notebook has a cup a bit longer
startup time than the Jupiter this is a
bit inconvenient
um in the beginning
but yeah
um it's just a different kind of
notebook and one thing which it does is
to execute everything in the beginning
so in Jupiter you just start the Jupiter
interactive shell yeah so you can
interact with python and nothing is
executed on the start but then in Pluto
actually everything is executed on the
start and this is why it needs a bit
longer and I prepared here kind of a
notebook
which we are now going to look into
What's the timing we have 40 minutes
okay so yeah
I think we
we are on track still
so the key things I want to show you in
this notebook is actually how Julia
manages to do this speed up so Julia's
unique Advantage is that it's both
simple and fast
and of course there are also
disadvantages yeah so how Julia does
this is using just in time compilation
but yeah this is kind of an abstract
thing and it's hard to to think about
this how how you can achieve the speed
houses just in time compilation and yeah
and this interactive notebook gives you
an idea
um how you can use this and how Julia
Works to get the speed up
and yeah
so first thing yeah first little
introduction to the plota notebook and
then to the two ingredients
um Julia has to to get the speed up
so Pluto is Interactive reactive so to
say if you re-execute something
everything else changes and it also has
support for some nice uis
so it's a little slider but you can
build more complex stuff and yeah it's a
bit tiny but you see kind of things
change we have we change here the value
of B we're using this extra macro bind
more details at Pluto pluto.jl
and we have another cell where we
multiply it by two we have a little
Matrix here which we Define and
everything changes
if we change something and this is kind
of the beauty you more or less have just
a code file which is always re-executed
for you
and yeah and this last part here is just
the plots heat map so all the plotting
is in here
okay
now to the two ingredients so the first
one
um which makes Julia fast uh the
so-called structs
this is also one disadvantage Julia
doesn't have object orientation as you
know from python
and this is mostly because of this
performance reason and what Julia has
are kind of structs which also can have
a type hierarchy but if you want to
store some values if you have some state
which you want to handle you only can
store State at the very so-called Leaf
types yeah so you have kind of have an
abstract
um yeah type hierarchy yeah but these
are only for overloading we're going to
see this and if you want to store real
estate you always need to take one of
the leaf types and you can't inherit
from this so this is the big
disadvantage if you love narrative
inheritance then
yeah
yeah it's not not directly mapable to
Trulia but the advantage is that given
this
um layout the structs really have C
performance
and we have here two structs a cat and a
dog and you see here that we can also
um yeah have some fields and we can also
assign types to the fields
by default if you define such a struct a
field always has to type any so it can
store anything but this is usually quite
bad for performance
so yeah you usually want to have kind of
some type annotations
then we can Define some types yeah so we
have utf-8 support so we have a nice cat
we have a nice dog and we can access uh
the fields like normal
so this is the first part and the second
part
are the functions and yeah just knowing
these two you're already ready to Define
whatever Jeweler you want yeah
so the functions are like in Python
generic functions you don't need to
specify types by default a function just
works for any type so if you want this a
little bit like duct typing
and we here now see kind of a string
with actually the interpolation syntax I
mentioned before with the dollar sign
but now on real string not in a Julia
code
and yeah we just have a describe
function here and we can describe our
Cad and we can describe our dog and we
just output this little string we can
also have functions with multiple
arguments as you see yeah and we can
also meet our cats and dogs and we have
also the possibility to write generic
functions which reuse our other
functions and this looks kind of super
intuitive and this is why python is so
famous yeah because writing this kind of
generic functionality is quite tough in
statically typed languages yeah so in
Python you're used to this this is
totally normal but it's really kind of
one of the benefits python gives you and
in Julia you have kind of the same flow
you can just write your generic
functions and everything will work and
the nice thing about Julia now so here
this is our little story now
this Kitty is Dexter and kitty meets
Dexter and the thing Julia gives now in
addition is that we can overload
functions anywhere where we want and I
have here kind of incremented a couple
of lines and if I now add this extra
function yeah so I have a special
function which now only works for dogs
so this is the double colon here and
specifying the type
and now we know this is a dog so we also
have the name ndh and can give a little
bit more description here
and you see everything else already
updated but because of the limited space
I need to scroll down
so
um we have this describe over here which
updated and also in our little story
um we also now got the right specialized
function so this is kind of the key idea
in Julia we just specialize our
functions for the concrete types and now
the just time compiler picks the right
one and we can do the very same the
described one was now a single argument
we can also do the same with multiple
arguments as we want so if we now meet a
cat with a dog we also have a special
thing which we want to print out
and you see it here at the top at the
bottom that also everything else updated
again so this is the advantage of using
Pluto and we really have the special
case kicking in and if we do something
else here then we have the general
General case as a fallback
so this is the key idea behind Julia we
have the of the one hand the structs
which are very efficient
and on the other hand the generic
functionalities and we can specialize
our functions to whatever we want and by
this getting the performance benefits
and this is really the same mechanism
which is used to speed up all the other
things so this is the key idea
please one question
two questions
I don't know no sorry yeah and then
there's also the question does
okay so the first question was how the
structures compare to go I don't know
the second one was um uh whether it's
really used some intermediate
representation it definitely does and
that some byte representations
and definitely it's different from
python for sure because it's in the seed
a family and yeah but
more details I don't know so what's
interesting and truly you can actually
find your own byte types that might be a
nice thing to be at to edit here
so in float and all these things yeah
they are actually defined within Julia
so there's a more fundamental byte type
which you can use to implement all these
things
but yeah I'm sorry no more details on
the questions
okay to save some time I think it's
actually good to to make a stop here I
just make a sure thing over the last
part so here in this Pluto one I because
this is the Julia side of things yeah I
know went the the other way so I
imported some python here and doing some
numpy stuff here on Julia arrays and
yeah and finally also a little
performance test and
um here a little example taken from
Julia Computing a quite old example I
pimped it up for today's Julia and this
constructs
set
we are tiny little example but it also
has kind of the specific part that you
really have your own logic yeah is this
now part of the model set or not yeah
this is a quite specific tiny function
so this is where Julia usually can give
you a huge speed up to have some some
individual logic which you just want to
implement fast and we see kind of
depending on how large we make this with
um of this little image if we compute it
in Julia versus python we get kind of a
performance speed UPS up to factor 30
but also interesting if we go completely
down here
um python is faster
so if you only have 10 by 10 then python
somehow manages to be faster but for any
reasonable size
Julia is faster and if you go thousand
by thousand I don't make the C because
it takes H is for python
um there yeah we have a speed up of
factor 50 in this example
and yeah you can kind of take a look at
the implementations here and the nice
thing also you see are using a different
interface actually just that you know
there are different ways to interact
with Julia I'm using pi call here while
in the other part I would recommend Pi
control but this little thing here is
really nice and Julia we can use a pie
in front of a multi-line string and then
just have some python being run
so in the sense if I come from Julia and
want to call python I I really like this
little
um yeah string helper here
but the other way around coming from
python to Julia I prefer the other
package
and hence my recommendation
Okay so
yeah this was part one and two from the
tree introduction quite a quick one I
hope you're still with me
um I now want to jump to the final
example of giving kind of a performance
comparison of this simulation example
but still other some questions for the
for the Julia site here
please
do you have some recommendations for
what use cases you would want to go with
python a python Julia set up over
something like Pi spark dusk or
something similar
what would be a recommended application
okay
um
yeah
that's a good one
um so in in general python is kind of
your tool if you want to plug and play
yeah so this is kind of where python
really shines because it is this huge
ecosystem
so yeah I think using python as your
glue language kind of is kind of nice
works and
yeah so so for example you have so one
thing I remember is that you have kind
of some psychic learn thing here or you
you want to use some specific machine
learning algorithm yeah you have a
python implementation but it's somehow a
bit crappy yeah I don't know you really
need to have it fast so one way is
actually really to re-implement the
thing in Julia it's not super hard yeah
you can just go if you really need this
for production somewhere this is an easy
way and chances are because this is also
the field where Julia is quite big that
someone else did this already for you
and then you can just yeah use this
implementation instead of the pythons I
could learn one and you get some speed
UPS Julia is also well done for threaded
computation and for multi-process
computation so it may also be that you
find kind of a threaded implementation
for the favorite algorithm in Julia
while there's none in Python because
shredded stuff is a bit difficult in
Python
um
yeah so something like this I think it's
a good example okay so then I would jump
to the last and final part
I'm glad you're all still with me and
now we going to look into some
uh want an example from multi-threaded
guy I I definitely had this wrong
uh in a second I have your name correct
so I took an example from the web where
I
yeah I think this is kind of a really
good example
sure what went wrong
um
so here we are
so for you the binder link should just
work
and this is the third one
okay so it's the multi-agent AI guy so
thank you multi-agent AI guy for giving
me the the core of this little example I
extended it a little bit here and there
fixed some things and yeah especially
also added a Julia version
so what is this about
um there the multi-agent AI guy also
made a nice little video it's mostly
black
but so what is that it's doing is to
simulate just a couple of predators
plants and praise and yeah they they
move around and if they need each other
then they eat each other according to
kind of some very simple rules
so this is the thing which we want to
Benchmark and I think it's a kind of a
good example because it's just a
specific little thing yeah you want some
simulation of whatever to test something
out to get some error benchmarks or yeah
get some idea how it could behave here
um get some intuition so this is kind of
a good thing and simulation is also yeah
very individual and uses a couple of
resources because you need to do a lot
of steps and you may want to speed this
up and yeah do this a million times to
get some confidence intervals I don't
know yeah so simulation is actually kind
of a good example
the code we're going to look at won't
output any anything actually so we
really only focus on the performance
comparison but
yeah in this link I posted here on the
top
um there's also kind of a way to
translate this then to a nice Pi game
visualization so if you want um you can
also take this and it's not so difficult
to get this visualization out of it
Okay so
a new notebook we again initialize our
Julia setup in the back
and then we
going to
um yeah import some python stuff
we initialize our random seeds I take
this kind from the example depending of
whether you want to have it reproducible
or just random you don't need to do this
um yeah and we have a word with and the
word hate this is the standard values
from the blog post and the timestamp
which I adjusted a little bit to yeah
have a bit more interactive Jupiter
session because things otherwise take a
bit longer
okay so we now look into the python
implementation just yeah we are
we're approaching the first hour and
yeah so
it's a bit more code be with me but I
think it's worth it because it's really
one of yeah the examples where you also
see how you can kind of map a type
hierarchy so I think this is a really
good example to get a an easy idea how
to translate stuff from python to Julia
so we have a patent agent class which
has a Constructor
and just analyze initializes a couple of
things and if we don't give it a X and Y
it gets a random start position
and yeah everything is alive on on the
beginning but it may die if it's eaten
and the key thing is here's an update
method so this very agent
can eat food and this logic just takes
food and it eats it so if you use this
class falsely then you have a plant
eating a filter but of course we take
care so that only praise can eat plant
and predators can eat praise
and yeah so with this update logic
there's kind of the simulation taking
place things get older that's nice and
yeah we also chase a Target that's also
kind of nice simulation we choose
um yeah if if there's kind of a Target
nearby we kill it
and get more energy and if we don't have
a Target we search for a new Target
and then we speed up here a little bit
uh the movement
and we also found it is a bit later and
actually if we have enough energy we're
going to see this we're going to split
up and get more of us so it's a nice
little simulation yes let's just tiny
example we have a couple of things you
need to be careful to do it right so
that you really see something happening
but this was done so thank you very much
second part of this is kind of to
execute the simulation and because I'm
using now also sighton to compare I put
this extra classes here in the main
method that's one cool thing of python
yeah you just can do this put a class
definition inside a function no problem
so yeah
pure Dynamic function at pure Dynamic
language it's really nice that this
works okay so
our main function then just initializes
some praise and predators and some
plants
and they just get randomly initialized
we only have this world with and World
height which we put in there so it's
really yeah simple stupid
python so 10 10 100 some constants just
make it simple and we have a couple of
time steps and this was set to a 2000
Now by me but we can also set it
somewhere to something else
we update everything so we eat in a
sense and then we filter all these
things which died out which we are
kicking them out we add some new plants
every turn so that things are growing
constantly and and praise have something
to eat and if we have kind of a praise
which have enough energy they split up
so that new praise are going to be added
to the field and same for Predators but
they need a bit more energy to to get a
new predator
so there was a a quick one through this
idea
so now you have the idea what we want to
write yeah we wrote this in Python
and yeah and this thing works and
there's also kind of in the source code
one alternative which was written then
insighton definitely not optimal saitan
yeah so you can definitely take more out
of sidon but just adding a couple of
type definitions here and there you get
a little speed up
so yeah okay this was unexpected
um
I haven't executed the python agent okay
so
if we Benchmark this now
um I have this extra minus error minus r
which is the number of runs you see that
counting is quite difficult yeah so we
have four runs here
and but still okay
um it's it's very important because the
python one is the the slowest we have
kind of 2.37 seconds but it's also
important to keep in mind here this is a
simulation yeah it's this really random
stuff and what is output here in the
very end is the number of predators the
number of praise and the number of
plants so you get an idea that these are
really different runs yeah so here we
have no Predators on the end yeah and
tons of plants and and this kind of
thing yeah so yeah take these numbers
with a grain of salt but still you see
kind of a good Improvement and this is
kind of a cool thing of Satan yeah we
can just use this class and take it as a
normal python class and already get a
speed up so this is a flexible
interaction we can't do this with Julia
actually it just takes too much time but
Satan is well made for this object
inheritance and we can do this it's
already a huge speed up
so we can get a bit more if we do also
the main method in in sighton we get a
further speed up
and yeah you see also there yeah this is
important to see okay they're really
different runs it's not all zero not all
predators but we have some some good
Randomness and we get another factor of
yeah two let's say yeah so just also
putting the
um the main method into site and we get
another Vector of two and now the C plus
plus alternative so
thank you
um
this is also
um implemented by the multi-agent AI guy
there was one little thing one little uh
error in the C plus plus implementation
I need to make a post to him so that he
can change it
so that the simulation is really the
same and so the g t plus code gets
compiled using um
G plus plus and
yeah then gives us an executable agent
and we can just time it here I was not
able to get the perf command running on
this Jupiter was really difficult so I
yeah this I usually use for really
timing things on the command line
but so we use the sub process and and
run our little C plus simulation and you
see that there's some difficulty here
with the randomness yeah so everything
before was really kind of switching here
and there but still we have kind of a
couple of things so I think this is fine
and our speed here is now 60
milliseconds so this is still a factor
of two faster than the Satan version
Okay so
that's the key comparison and now comes
the final part where we want to put this
into Julia
okay so yeah we have 30 minutes for this
and this is kind of cool that's enough
time so you see my little your space
advice and it mentions
please delete all of these cells and I
think uh because we have the time I
would like to do this so
this is the solution yeah and now it's
gone
okay
so
[Music]
um
yeah so please be invited to do this
with me
um
now we we're going to construct this in
Julia and I want to kind of give you the
the feeling that this is actually
um yeah something you can do as well
so the first thing and this is the most
important thing I think which which will
pop up a couple of times
we have this type hierarchy but actually
in Julia we don't have this type
hierarchy we can just not simply inherit
so we have this agent at the top and we
have this Predator praise and plants so
luckily we we don't do anything fancy
here yeah so actually all these
Predators spray and plants they just set
this V Max the maximum
um speed the velocity with which they
can move
and yeah we can just set this parameter
by by setting the value in the Aging
Constructor so what we're going to do is
we just use one struct we have one one
simple object which has all our values
and we initialize it differently if we
want to pray or if we want to plant
Okay so
hence the first step is to build kind of
our struct
and I take this little thing here
so let's
take a look
and I yeah I'm going back here so this
is our python agent just a Constructor
and we're going to move this to Julia
and yeah and Julia we don't have strong
class but structs we can call this a
Julia agent
and Julia we also don't have this colon
at the end we can inherit by using
um this little thing and we can make it
I don't know an abstract array
but we don't we don't want to
okay so everything is finalized with an
end and Julia
let's make this two here okay
and now we can
just put our field names here like we've
seen this with the cat and dog
and we can probably speed this up a
little bit
and we would also like to have yeah it
looks good
so what's a little bit disadvantaged and
Julia is um okay by default we actually
don't have this initial values so if you
just use this it will fail it's a bit
unfortunate but as Julia is quite
powerful in The Meta language
actually it's already very old there's a
little helper in the base
it's kind of one of this modules which
allowed it by default most standard
functions are in there and most of them
you can access directly but for some you
need to use the qualified access by
putting base dot in front and for the
keyboard definition it's still the case
for current Julia
and with this yeah we can use the the
default arguments
so we are
the world with
I also like default arguments here and
we already have these
these Capital case versions We already
have defined
and
yeah so now we are at the X values and
we we don't have them set so this is the
default value and we need to get some
random number and actually this is quite
handy and Julia we have the colon to
make a range and the rent function can
pick us a value from this range
and this actually works so we now access
this other value here and this just
works fine if they are under another
and
yeah we can do the same here and
have this here have this here
true and false uh written lowercase
and there's the something like nothing
like none but it's called nothing and
Julia also lowercase
okay then we have H
and energy
so and this is a good start I think this
is everything have I overlooked
something I think Linda
okay so now we have our type and we can
already test this so that you can get an
idea this actually works we can
initialize this because everything has
default values and now we get our Julia
agent so that's the the first part yeah
so little helper here keyword definition
but with this
it's kind of K yeah so nothing super
fancy
um you can do this of course you always
need to do the mapping yeah if you have
some python stuff here
Google is your friend or shed GPT and
then yeah you usually get a good answer
yeah a little a little freaky yeah so
you really need to do this this mapping
but okay you you can make it it's just
for speeding up a tiny part
okay so next part is to do this update
and there we already see kind of a
little bit the spirit of Julia in Python
we we have this
um our object function that we would now
have this update logic somewhere here
there within our object but in Julia
this is just
um yeah differently designed we don't do
this and Julia all the functionality
they are separate so we really have this
distinction of the structs and the
functions as I showed you in the Pluto
notebook and hence we really do our
update function separately
and we can Define some types
like Julia agent but we don't need to
yeah so remember we our update function
always updated our little agent and get
some food and it's helpful to name our
agent also safe so we now really have
kind of the same namings as in Python
and what sorts are coming in Julia is
that we actually use the exclamation
mark at the end if we want to indicate
that something is mutated and this is
the case here we have our agent and we
mutate our agent and this is kind of a
nice convention I like this so let's put
an exclamation mark in the end okay
update so let's go to the top and get
our update logic
so
it's a bit
a bit larger but we'll make it and
otherwise we just take our solution
Okay so
it's the very same let's take this down
one level
and end at the end
so main purpose of this is that you see
this is really intuitive yeah so I hope
this message comes and yeah let's see so
we have our update logic and we get some
food in there
so this update here is the very same
yeah we can actually make this a bit
more condensed so plus equals also
exists
so if we can't move we return that's
almost the same and Julia we don't have
this double colon but we need to end
things with an end
so if safe Target and not save Target is
alive so this is a bit more complex
because this means just a python Boolean
check yeah which is a bit fancy
um Dynamic python thing and we know that
our thing is nothing here
so in Julia we usually compare directly
with this nothing value this is our
special part so yeah we have here a
Target which is not nothing so we have a
real Target and
and doesn't exist we need to use double
um yeah this is also the end python I
think
this double at
end sign
and not just also not exist the
exclamation mark is used
but the other thing is the same again
semicolon at the end back and the end
and none of course
isn't there so we set it to nothing
okay so this is the opposite if save
Target it's again the same
so Square distance and Julia we really
have this
um oh we don't know the name actually so
yeah we can square it with the usual
operator is a special operator
and
we need to get everything with an end so
false needs to be written lower case
yeah these tiny things some of them can
be automatized
but usually it's beat up of a tiny part
so it's easily also done by hand
Okay so
why not let's make a plastic where it's
known
okay if not save Target so this means if
this thing is nothing yeah
we do a for Loop four Loops can be
written similarly we just don't have
this column at the end and
get everything finished with an end
statement
it's not it's not existent you use the
same like we did for the nothing the
three equal signs or exclamation mark
with within and T again the end
and you get you get the idea yeah so
this is the thing which you do then but
other than that it's really kind of easy
going the semantics are similar yeah
it's really a dynamically typed language
it's just just in time compiled but the
flow it goes is like it's the same like
in pi and you don't need to care about
static types it will just work the same
the static types in Julia are really
just for speed up the thing will do the
same just slower if you don't use the
type information so you can always be
sure
that you can just work like python
um and then yeah you add some types of
speed up but you don't need to care for
them
so it's the same flow as in Python so
definitely I did some
yeah I know it looks good okay so we
have
um this safe Target if this exists so
these things and I think I will leave it
by the update method and copy the main
method from the solution
um it's straightforward but it takes
some time
so
I
ate one of these
okay so there we are
okay so this is our update method
this was it and we mutated
a lot of the save and of course this is
Julia
so we need to do this in Julia
okay
that's a bit tedious so I now go to the
repository and go to copy the main
method
of course you're invited to do this
really by hand and experience it
um
but yeah so let's
copy the main function
what's the time
yeah okay
so there we are back
the main function let me explain to you
kind of what are the key parts for for
this translation
so Julia also has keyword arguments
but you activate them if you put a
semicolon in front so this is a tiny
little thing so this is um
in front you have kind of the position
arguments here
and after the semicolon the keyword
arguments come and the Julia this is
important to distinguish because you
have this overloading yeah you can
specialize the functions for arbitrary
types and the specialization this only
happens on the positional part
still it's very handy to use keyword
arguments if you just want to write an
interface function yeah like such a main
method so yeah it's well supported and
you also don't need to be afraid that
you lose kind of performance yeah this
is also also yeah type supported
yeah it's just if you use Julie a bit
more then this is kind of standard but
in the first side it looks a little bit
alien to have this semicolon in front
but then it's just um normal yeah python
syntax as well so we initialize here a
show function to get rid of some
printings but then we have this word
with World hate and timestamps
and this is kind of one extra thing so
in Julia you get the speed UPS if you
use functions
and this worldwidth and World hate and
time steps they are defined globally
yeah we we just assigned them to our
Global namespace so Julia supports this
that you can use this but the global
variable is like a black box for Trulia
this is yeah you can Implement some
fancy logic with this yeah you can
assign the global variables from some
other thread and then take it again yes
you can do fancy stuff with it but in
Julia usually these Global variables
they have the type any
and this is Handy but it can kind of cut
down performance so actually if we used
the time steps for example here yeah we
have this while loop it will check every
time okay my time steps Global variable
yeah have you changed in the meanwhile
ah no you haven't changed yeah
um but it really doesn't know and it
will always check okay are you still
have the right type are you still in
yeah and interacting with global
variables yeah has some performance
impacts so the the thing which you
usually see is that you just put them
like here in function arguments so as a
default value here so the function will
be initialized and then it now is okay
for this function execution my time
steps is really an integer yeah and it's
really this value and then Julia can do
all the rest it's a tiny thing but just
good to know and as you're here to to
learn this thing
um I think it's kind of a nice little
extra
so tiny little helper gives you some
speed ups and looks good so you can also
parameterize it other than that we have
kind of keyword arguments and we use
also named tubids you see this is the
very same syntax as here with the
semicolon in front and actually we don't
need to write out the the extra part
yeah we can just leave it and it will
take the the name as it is so this is a
kind of a shortcut then we initialize
everything same we have the four
comprehensions here and again the
semicolon to use the keyword arguments
but otherwise the same we have the time
step we have the Y Loop we have a for
Loop to update now we use the
exclamation mark method here and yeah we
filter this is a little speed up in pi
you can also kind of do a four
comprehension again here by filtering
with an if statement but it creates a
new array
and actually the C plus plus version
also just filtered so I thought it was
fair to also use the filter version here
we append we go through it for Loop
filter push appends to the arrays and
this is kind of it yeah so it's really
the same idea as in Python just tiny
mapping between functions there's one
question over there thank you
on this
Constance or the word hype order yeah
am I understanding it right yeah so
python doesn't care so much because it
doesn't check the types to to improve
performance and then Julia this is
really done every time and we're going
to see this actually
um yeah so it's really for the compiler
it will work the very same way and Julia
it's just slower and the more this type
information is available the more Julia
can actually optimize its code on the
Fly
thank you
please run further Christian
s
so the initialization we did in the
I'm initializing it here but you're
right yeah yeah I I did give a default
over there yeah
yeah no this is yeah not used
yeah the question was um thank you for
reminding
um that above we defined our nice struct
with some default values and also for
World hate and World width and we don't
use it yeah so this is is correct and
yeah it's just
yeah I think this was part of the
translation to Julia and then it doesn't
make all sense but it's good enough
thank you for the question
okay so there we are yeah everything is
defined and now we can run it
and
this the super interesting part okay
okay let's let's take a look
nah correct correct thank you okay so so
let's do the C on the top we have our
Julia agent so there was a comment that
I haven't defined
um the sub parts and
um there's a a nice thing
so it's super quick defined
and
does someone of you can tell me what the
values are for the keyword VMAX
okay for the prey please
2.5 okay
2.0
Okay so
order is random predator
and plant
so you see this one is really simple
isn't it as so we just
overwrite kind of one of these default
values and we got rid of inheritance
bam okay so let's check whether this
works
um
ah of course of course
ah yeah good one
um
10 minutes left we get there
the default struct and Julia
is unfortunately or ninja is
intentionally immutable and you need to
add an extra mutable command to really
make it mutable and because the structs
are so important Julia they actually
cannot be redefined if something like
this crucially changed you need to
restart the Julia session and it's a
little disadvantage but I think it's
because of optimization so I renamed it
now to get rid of this difficulty
okay last try if it doesn't work I take
the other solution okay take the other
solution
none is not defined have you seen a nun
ah there none come come I'm so motivated
um
math not defined
so we use the math function somewhere
square root
square root is just
um normal
yeah we don't need to use math it's one
of the standards
it's good doesn't it
okay so key thing is
this is slow
and this is still a bit faster than
python I think python was a bit more
than two seconds yeah but it's a really
slow we're definitely not at the 60
millisecond 60 milliseconds yeah and now
comes the last piece and this is the
type information
and yeah and this is kind of the crucial
part so you you see yeah this is really
just 1.6 seconds and and C plus plus was
60 60 milliseconds so really need to
speed this up otherwise this would be a
terrible Workshop
and
um and the key thing is it looks almost
identical
yeah is that we add some type
information to our
um struct type
so it works yeah and it's all fine but
it works just much faster
um
if we
add type information
and I regain changed the name to not
confuse Julia and yeah it's the very
same just added some type information
here
and yeah and do you have some special
thing here the agent is a union of a
nothing and an agent so that we can set
it to into nothing and this is of course
a typed agent now I need to change okay
so
um sure this is Julia code
okay and now now Okay so
let's
damn it okay so I did some extra
adaptation somewhere so I need to
also get the
update method ready
so it worked for the standard case but
because we set the type we now have kind
of some some type conversion kicking in
and yeah and apparently this is
this was not accounted for in my little
spontaneous version so I just overwrote
it yeah so this is also super awesome in
Julia we can just overwrite
a function and it will pick up the new
one and now bam this should be faster
okay
so I can't yeah okay so this is very
optimistic yeah
so we are now down to four milliseconds
and there's another macro Benchmark
which we haven't used so far but now
it's quite nice and they also turn off
the output
and there we see kind of a little bit
more
um the distribution
and we also see information about the
garbage collection and this is kind of
key thing which also is kind of
difference between Julia and C plus plus
that we don't have the garbage collector
and Julia we have it which is yeah
depending on your use case and advantage
on disadvantage but for just quickly
typing it's a usually an advantage to
have a garbage collector and here you
see kind of we range from what we see
above this is kind of our minimal case
with almost zero yeah with zero garbage
collection to something
um around 63 milliseconds which was the
C plus plus I'm timing roughly yeah if
our garbage collector kicked in a bit
more
and meantime median time here 46. Okay
so
I'm glad we went we came to this point
yeah so
um this is kind of the key idea you can
speed up even more Julia yeah so we now
just added kind of the type information
in the in the struct yeah this is kind
of the key part the interface so to say
yeah
which is then handled but of course
Julius of course but Julia is really
meant for high performance Computing so
there are a couple of extra things you
can do yeah you can turn off bound
checks on arrays and stuff like this you
can really get low level and get more
speed out of it even more so this is
kind of the standard yeah speed up and
if you really like to get more
performance out of it the Airways to do
that as well
yeah so okay
um I think this is good I have kind of
two minutes left so there I have a lot
of further resources here follow me on
LinkedIn and you can also reach me at my
email I'm very glad to have you today
and we have one minute for questions for
further questions uh thank you for being
with me today it was a pleasure
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah number is awesome yeah same
approach number is kind of restricted to
a sub language of python same as checks
so yeah and yeah you just need to
confirm the sub language then then you
get probably similar speed ups but you
still have this friction with python
itself and Julia it's kind of default
all custom types are there and you don't
need to care about this language
difference
recommend using Julia as a back end for
a python package if so can we get a
binary package so that the user doesn't
have to install Julia first yeah awesome
question so this is actually in the
summary you can actually compile Julia
down to a C library
so the question is whether we can get
rid of the Julia executable and we can
but it just usually doesn't make sense
for this experimentation yeah so it just
Julia has downloaded for you for with
his packages and it runs but if you want
to get to production and you want to get
rid of the Julia part um you can do so
and compile Julia to a C library
mhm
oh two minutes
okay I'm not sure question over there
please yeah
you know image
yeah
so the question is how to deal with
other individual types how they are
mapped I have no experience to admit
yeah so in general they are just
pointers to the python objects and then
you kind of access the python objects
and if in this complex thing there
somewhere is a numpy array you can still
access this and use kind of the numpy
speed up
um but yeah in general I think you yeah
you have kind of this this flower axis
until you have the data you want and
then you run in Julia and yeah and then
you output kind of something and this
workflow should work with all custom
types also
yeah
one question over here
about
most of the popular algorithms are
implemented CNC right
yes yeah
so the question is whether um how to
compare to your performance with C
especially with machine learning I think
performance is very similar and usually
Yeah the code is much much smaller
because you have this support for
exactly this Applied Mathematics
mathematics
yeah so you can expect similar
performance and depending on how good
the C code is written the Julia might be
faster
okay so this was it I'm here for further
questions you see me I have this nice
Julia thing here and yeah so thank you
for being here but you can also come
here to the front and ask more questions
I'm there
our time is over thank you again and see
you at the conference enjoy it